alors alexandre jardin suis le fils de
pascal jardin lui-même fils de jean
jardin dont son père a beaucoup parlé
dans le linge au nez tu a attaqué très
fort en littérature avec bille en tête
en 86 que le prix du premier roman
alors est ce que tu crois que le talent
est héréditaire en général
non mais pour moi est ce que tu crois
que ton nom de famille et le nom de ton
éditeur gallimard en l'occurrence
cantons et des sites et tu veux pas tu
te rappeler du gland chez lieu commun
est ce que tu crois que ça aurait marché
aussi bien si je disais non est ce que
ce que je te croirais pas alors en ce
moment tu cartonne encore plus fort avec
le z en a combien la 125 me pâme agents
du sa lettre en film whip it qui fait
l'adaptation à toi elle n'a jamais fait
les producteurs de lait se faire
l'adaptation d'un fait de jeu déjà
vendus à bon d'accord ils seront tournés
ce qu'ils veulent alors tu sais que dans
cette émission fait des interviews à un
concept est donc pour toi bien
évidemment je peux pas faire autrement
que le questionnaire de proust alors à
faire comme un proust express
le compte de la nisa mieux compte de
misère c'est pour moi c'est une symbiose
couple qui s'appelle papa et maman entre
entre eux alors là c'est autant que
marié toit
oui mais je n'ai aucunement l'intention
du lap et affable même quand elle aura
des enfants
non non tu appelles pas ma femme des
rentes heureusement tu l'appelle par son
prénom d'une minute par son prénom ma
maîtresse quand j'en parle
ouais maîtresse les gars c'est comment
son prénom est laide ou aimerais-tu
vivre à côté d'elle quel est ton idéal
de bonheur terrestre
le veer de faire des succès en même
temps que mon père c'est là qu'ils
soient vivants ou et que et qu'on
cartonne tous les deux alors sa manche
entre eux alors ça repart l'alleud
sally le nain jaune mais je vais y
brière qui me dit quand je pose une pile
de nage libre c'est un peu tu es le
nageur tour derrière réserve way
tonnerre une favorite dans la vie réelle
mon héroïne favorite
je crois que c'est ma mère ou en numéro
deux la femme qui m'a attiré vers le
roman alors je ne voulais pas écrire
c'est qui c'est c'est françoise verjux
j'ai une vraie passion pour cette pour
cet énorme de femmes c'est elles qui t'a
fait écrire un nom qui mec qui m'a fait
écrire durement ouais je ne voulais pas
écrire rendement et c'est elle qui va
attraper
j'ai pas pu faire autrement elle n'a
coincé campagne favoris
c'est un peintre mais ce sont ses
dessins ouais c'est que j'adore les
dessins de goya ouais ils discutent du
carré qui a tué avec des visages
inquiétants
il ya une vraie folie et
et ils m'ont fm quoi ton musiciens de
musique de jeunes nous
de musique classique les musiques
j'aime beaucoup les rengaines ouais
j'aime le top 50
ah oui j'aime beaucoup décidément
t'abonner au top 50 ce soit pour les
lire oui j'aime beaucoup les rengaines
populaire de qualité préféré chez un
homme qui m'aime je n'aime pas je suis
une femme quelle méthode
bonne occupation préférée à l'occupation
c'est d'essayer de trouver des moyens de
faire rêver ma femme ouais alors ça
c'est mon cas oui mais c'est mon grand
c'est d'essayer de trouver des astuces
pour les tenez pour continuer à
surprendre
c'est mon cas c'est le sujet du bouquin
mais c'est réellement je collectionne
pas les temps je m'occupe de ma femme
trimestre qui s'était pas alexandre
jardin
moi je n'aurais pas aimé être qu'un jour
tu messi mais comment ça se comprend
mais si je devais me réincarner en une
bulle de chantôme très plaisir
son principal défaut à toi moi troisième
fois je ne le vois pas très honnêtement
pas un peu prétentieux par hasard
si voilà tu en rêves de bonheur c'est
quoi un don de faire le prince charmant
a battu le fait très bien
non mais de faire avec la même femme
quand même pas de papillonner
non non ça ça me fait pas rêver oh là là
tu vas france est folle mais ça peut
arriver
c est la société sur ton livre encore
plus peut-être tout en auteurs favoris
entre aux as par alexandre jardin
il y en a un que je préfère de beaucoup
c'est céline ouais c'est louis ferdinand
céline parce que tout c'est que chaque
semaine dans l'émission avec céline way
aussi ouais et j'ai dû lire 30 x 40 x
je suis aux antipodes de ce bonhomme
un grand salopards et je suis subjugué
quoi j'imagine qu'on doit être quelques
millions le ton de la nature ne t'a pas
parce qu'elle est bien sympa quand même
et tu voudrais avoir fait d'être doué
c'est très dur maintenant
non non je dire de deux des types comme
ça qui par exemple peuvent écrire d'un
travail le non non moi je ne peux pas
décrire
oui j'suis pas bon il me faut revenir
mille fois sur le métier ça s'il voyait
une fille qui perd ce soir et ça se voit
pas cantonner ce bouquin doit surtout
merci mais mais mais j'aimerais de doha
j'aimerais mourir comment très vieux
très vieux
j'ai besoin de beaucoup de temps je veux
je vais vivre très longtemps déjà
oui mais je suis très pressé
et je veux que ça dure je je je veux
faire un bon vieux l'état présente son
esprit là maintenant présent à chaque
fois que je viens dans une émission de
télé ça fait très plaisir
non parce que la télé ça quelque chose
d'un peu jubilatoire j'aime bien parce
que chaque instant pour chaque instant
compte alors que dans la vie on perd du
temps on va aux chiottes on a été là on
va rarement aux chiottes sortir et pour
être sûr de ne rien rater de dinars 10
tubes abonnez vous je m'étais un peu ce
bleu